italian food Ranking schauen wir mal was
so kommt ich liebe italienisches Essen
Pasta boah es gibt zwar auch Pizza aber
ich glaube Pasta muss direkt auf die ein
ich liebe Pasta über alles als nächstes
nooki ich würde sagen goldene Mitte
gehen wir auf die fünf als nächstes
canoli bisschen overhye vielleicht
Kontroverse Meinung aber ich finde sieht
geil aus als ist Pizza auf die Z let's
go übelst nice Risotto schon sehr stark
ich tu es auf die vier weil vielleicht
kommt noch was geileres brusketta
brusketta ist hiy geiler bruskter könnte
ich jeden Abend essen auf die se
Süßspeisen mag ich nicht so gerne
Amaretti irgendwie ein bisschen unnötig
weil mag ich nur zu Espresso Tiramisu
auf die 7 und was muss auf die Z
Arancini okay tut mir leid weil Arancini
sind eigentlich übelst geil aber das ist
mein Ranking